le moment est maintenant venu de laisser
la place à la fête de la musique
antenne 2 y accordera ce soir une place
majeure en ouvrant son antenne à la nuit
du rock jusqu'au petit matin jusque vers
5 heures du matin je crois parmi les
vedettes de la nuit et bien il y aura le
groupe de rock français téléphone
ceux là même qui participent pourrait-on
dire à la réduction de notre déficit
extérieur puisqu'ils ont réussi à
importer le rock français a exporté le
rock français sur le sol américain
nous en parlerons d'ailleurs avec eux
tout à l'heure avec le chanteur jean
louis aubert
le garçon qui est à ma gauche avec une
une chemise tout chamarrés et le batteur
richard kolinka musique rock sur antenne
2 donc ce soir je ne sais pas si tout le
monde partagera ce plaisir en tout cas
si vous avez des grincheux et bien vous
faites comme le groupe téléphone ou les
invités à la fête
oh
il
ne sais quoi qui veulent être
pan
deux mois
ban
evans
malino
non
sherbrooke
le voir
le temps
deux mois
le ballon
bientôt les seconds ans
yamba
m
ça va être un peu près pareil il va y
avoir beaucoup d'atmosphère
on met longtemps à réaliser un clip
vidéo comme celui là qui a plein de
références cinématographiques on y voit
dulko dit buffalo bills on y voit
bogaert haut niveau à superman voyais
pas le temps pour les costumes et le
recrutement des sosies ces agences
anglaise qui est spécialisée dans les
les sosies et le tournage a duré un jour
et demi michèle cornut langlois ne
voulait poser une autre question
simplement pour vous demander si c'est
très efficace ce genre de promotion
parce qu'on le voit de plus en plus
développé un outil aussi bien chez les
français que chez les groupes anglo
saxons ouais ça fait presque partie du
disque que maintenant quand on finit le
dit son nom mais une ou deux chansons
clip comme ça ça nous permet d'avoir de
nous faire devancé sur les télés
régionales pendant la tournée
et puis moi je trouve que ça fait
pratiquement partie du disque
maintenance et des roues a vraiment du
plaisir à l'affairé du fleuron
l'alternance pas avant que l'histoire
finit des gens d'ici c'est vrai aux
lecteurs bah oui nico tellement saoul
alors demandé ya pas mal de gars qui va
voir en direct alors autant profiter
il ya une autre forme de promotion c'est
de se rendre au à l'extérieur et en
particulier aux états unis alors comme
rod stewart david bowie viennent d'avoir
un succès fou ici j'aimerais savoir vous
quand vous allez aux états unis vous en
venez le sol quelle centrale disons que
l'on joue dans des salles de 200 mille
personnes
on n'aurait pas lamblin oui on est allé
à tahiti on est revenus par los angeles
chicago et new york alors vous avez
l'air de rien quand vous parlez de
chicago je crois savoir que chicago
précisément ça n'a pas très bien marché
c'est à dire c'est un bon concert veille
avec eux
deux personnes dans le public l'heure vu
que nous on était déjà une bonne dizaine
états unis à new york en particulier
vous avez eu beaucoup de succès wen a
joué dans un club qui s'appelle le ritz
qui ressemble un peu au palace ici et là
c'était plein y avait a été étonné
d'ailleurs il y avait 2000 2500
personnes et on avait déjà joué une
quête une petite dizaine de fois new
york à chaque fois qu'on passe c'est à
dire que comme les voyages sont assez
assez cher des combats au canada où ou à
tahiti comme c'était le cas là on
s'arrête toujours à à new york ou à los
angeles il vous allez partir en suède et
là pour chanter pour la paix à goteborg
est ce que c'est en rapport avec notre
chanson je veux une arme
ben ça pourrait traverser avec cette
chanson est un grand festival qui se
passe ensuite tous les ans puis là nous
a proposé d'y aller je peux pas dire que
je suis très renseigné sera ce à quoi il
sert où va l'argent et tout ça mais je
me concernés par la paix tout de même
ouais non je pense à cette chanson la
paix dimanche
non non pas que vous allez jouer vous
c'est d'abord le vo2 le plaisir de jouer
semble-t-il pas la paix il ya pas mal de
gens qui sont pour la paix je pense que
deux personnes qui osera dire
ouvertement qu'il est pour la guerre
mais voilà c'est bien qu'ils aient des
grands festivals comme ça vous parliez
du palace tout à l'heure mais le palace
cepal votre public votre public c'est
plutôt un public de jeunes publics
d'ouvriers un public étudiant qui n'est
pas le
ce que l'on pourrait appeler le gratin
qui vaut palace quoi c'est à dire qu'on
a déjà joué au palace mais le palace
organise d'excellents concerts qui
s'adresse à à tout le monde
puis après il ya le le club une boîte de
nuit à paris c'est une boîte de nuit à
paris on y voit un peu toujours les
mêmes gens et alors vous allez
participer à la fête de la musique à
travers la nuit du rock sur antenne 2 ce
soir